thanks for inviting me and thanks for
staying around to the last day yeah so
this is relative error tensor low-rank
approximation joint work with gel song
and peléan Jung I realize this is a
pretty diverse audience so please stop
me there any questions okay so what is a
tensor a tensor is just a
multi-dimensional array so here's a cube
it's a third order tensor you have
parameters to describe a tensor okay so
you have some order Q so it's three here
and you have a dimension for each
direction of the tensor okay so n1
through NQ maybe this is an N by n by n
tensor yeah so Q equals three is a cube
Q equals two is just a matrix Q equals 1
is a vector and let's just set up some
notation for this so let's call these
vectors columns these vectors rows and
the vectors into the screen tubes and we
can also look at things like column row
faces so we can take columns and rows
together and we get a face of this cube
we can look at Row two faces and two
column faces okay so what we're going to
look at in this talk is generalizing a
lot of linear algebra problems and
machine learning problems that have been
developed over the years for matrices
two tensors okay so let me first say
what's known about matrices so let's
look at the low-rank approximation
problem
so suppose we're given an N by D matrix
a and the rank parameter K and some
accuracy parameter epsilon then what we
might like to do is to approximate our
matrix a with a low rank matrix a hat
okay so a hat is going to have rank K
and what we'd like is that if I look at
a hat - a it's small under some norm
okay and yeah so in particular what
we'll look at is the Frobenius norm
which is the Frobenius norm of a matrix
is just the sum of squares of the
entries to the one half what we'd like
is to find this rank K matrix a hat so
that the difference of a hat and a under
this norm is you know it's pretty small
say it's at most some approximation one
plus epsilon times the best possible
approximation of a by any rank K matrix
a prime okay yeah so again we're just
looking at for vinius norm here and any
rank K matrix can be written as the
product of two matrices U and V so U is
n by K and V is say K by D if a is an N
by D matrix and so you want to find
these factors of your low-rank
approximation there are many motivations
for computing a low-rank approximation
instead of storing this big n by D
matrix a I can instead store these two
factors U and V so my number of
parameters instead of being yeah
question perviness norm
you're gonna say anything about the
behavior of the linear system the system
is associated with yeah so I mentioned a
variety of different norms here
Frobenius norm is the main example we'll
focus on but yeah if you have a small
for vinius norm is small enough Rubinius
norm then you know if epsilon is zero
and this is actually a rank K matrix
then you'll recover the rain came matrix
but yeah there are other norms that are
better in certain situations yeah so a
nice thing here is you get a parameter
reduction right instead of nd parameters
to represent a you just store U and V
which is more like n plus D so it's n
plus D times K and K is supposed to be
this small integer if you're doing
low-rank approximation another nice
thing is you can multiply your matrix a
time's the vector very quickly right
instead of spending nd time to multiply
by a vector I spend like DK DK time to
multiply by a vector and then NK time to
multiply by that output times this so I
can multiply in roughly n plus D time as
well and a lot of matrices in real life
they actually are close to low rank they
might only not be low rank because of
some noise measurement noise or you know
or whatever and what you can think of
low-rank approximation as denoising your
matrix okay what yeah so pca for example
okay so you can solve you know over the
years people have developed randomized
algorithms for finding these factors U
and V and what we know now is we know
how to find such factors U and V very
quickly in time which is n in Z of a so
N and Z means number of nonzero entries
of a so it's sensitive to the sparsity
often times your matrices are sparse and
NZ of a plus what's typically a low
order term n plus d times polynomial and
K over Epsilon okay epsilon
approximation rank K okay any questions
okay so you could ask the same question
for tensors you know we have all these
results for matrices what about the
following questions
suppose I have in third order n by N by
n tensor a again a rank parameter K and
some approximation factor alpha and what
I'd like to do is I'd like to output a
rank K tensor a hat now I didn't say
what rank means yet for tensors hold
onto that for a second but suppose
there's some notion
I'd like to output a rank a tensor a hat
such that you know the norm of a hat
minus a is small and for vinius norm
here still makes sense right for vini
assume with just sum of squares of
entries of differences of entries why
why can't I ask the same question for
tensors sum of the squares of
differences so I'd like to output an a
hat so that the Frobenius norm of a hat
minus a is at most some approximation
factor alpha times the best possible
approximation to a by any rank a tensor
a prime all right okay so yeah so for
Britney storm is the same here let's
just call this quantity opt so we want
to output something with cost alpha
times opt okay so the first question is
you know what is the rank of a tensor so
there are multiple notions of rank and
the main notion we'll focus on in this
talk is what's called the canonical or
CP rank so what that is is you know one
way of defining the rank of a matrix is
just the minimum number of rank one
matrices I need to add up to get to my
matrix alright so I'm taking the outer
product of two vectors and I get a rank
one matrix and I'm adding them up and
getting my matrix that minimal integers
is the rank and you can say the same
thing for tensors all right I can take
three vectors and I can take you know
the outer product of these three vectors
I get u I cross V I across WI that's I'm
gonna call that a rank one tensor and
I'm asking what's the minimal number of
these I have to add up in order to get
my given tensor that's its rank okay
yeah so okay
let me just write the the the tensor in
a slightly different form in terms of
matrices so instead of this sum of outer
products of vectors let me write it as u
cross V cross W where u is n by K it's a
matrix V is n by K and W is n by K and
this just means exactly the same thing
as before
so what this operation means is I take
the first column of U I take its outer
product with the first column of V and
outer product with the first column of W
that's one rank one tensor and then I
add that to the outer product to the
second column of U out of product second
column of V out of public second column
of W is that right ok so these are the
factors the analogous factors that I
want to find in the tensor case yeah for
an N by n by n ten so if I if I take a
random and by N by n tensor yeah this
would be around n squared actually so
what yeah so let me get back to that
yeah so it's it's larger than n yeah but
we don't know how to construct explicit
tensors of rank larger than n yeah much
larger than n yeah any other questions
okay so yeah I mean so this has all the
same motivations that we had before
right we'd like to you know reduce the
number of families we don't want n cube
per ammeter is we want roughly like 3 n
K parameters you can also apply this
more quickly to a vector we can denoise
a tensor etc same motivations yeah okay
so yeah so before getting into that let
me just mention going back to a question
in the audience there are many other
norms you can look at for both matrices
and tensors right instead of Frobenius
norm
you could ask can I find a rank K matrix
these two factors U and V such that some
norm of UV transpose minus a is the most
alpha times the best possible norm under
for any rank K matrix approximating 8 so
the norm could be this Frobenius norm
that we talked about but in other
applications it might make sense to do
something like the entry wise l1 norm so
instead of the sum of squares of
differences maybe we just want the sum
of absolute values you know this is
often considered more robust because if
you have some grossly corrupted entry
then you're not paying as much attention
to it because you're not squaring it and
so you're paying more attention to the
remaining data this is the intuition
there are also other notions of robust
measures such as sum of l2 norms so
instead of taking the sum of squares of
all the entries I take the Euclidean
norm of a row and I each row and I add
up all these Euclidean norms this is
also more robust and it has a nice
geometric interpretation so the SVD the
similar value decomposition is trying to
minimize for Venus norm and what you can
think of that is doing is trying to find
a low dimensional subspace which
minimizes the sum of squares of
distances of all your rows of a to it
okay you're trying to find this low
dimensional subspace and thinking of the
rows of a is points you're trying to
minimize the sum of squares of distances
to this low dimensional subspace and
what this more robust thing is doing is
this trying to find this low dimensional
subspace which just minimizes the sum of
distances of the points to it which you
know since you're not squaring things is
often considered more robust and yeah so
other things you could look at
are like waited for Venus norm why
should all the entries of a you know
contribute the same amount to the
objective function this is useful when
you want to sort of renormalize some
entries by their variants like maybe
some entries are more corrupt than
others matrix completion is also a
special case of this where the weights
are zero and one I want to mention for
all the results cited here we make no
assumptions on the matrix a so this
these are for worst case matrices and we
get input sparsity running time and in Z
of a these problems other than the
Frobenius norm or all and be hard the
approximation ratio is they're not going
to be something like 1 plus epsilon that
we were talking about for Frobenius norm
there'll be a bit larger like polynomial
in this rank parameter k and and login
for example but ok so there many more
norms we can look at and we can also
look at all of these in the context of
tensors and yeah I don't really think I
need to motivate tensors to you guys but
you know these do tensor datasets
everywhere for instance you know
everywhere you have for instance a three
dimensional array maybe Facebook wall
posts you have some wall owner you have
someone who's posting on this wall you
have some time of day and the
corresponding entry in the in the tensor
is the number of posts made yeah
motivation for tensors okay so let me do
this motivation but you know it's sort
of anywhere you can think of a
three-dimensional array so is there an
analog adventures
for general tensors no yeah so there are
things called like orthogonal tensors
where you can have analogs
but but in general no yeah there's no
like SVD or anything like that for
tensors yeah the approximation factors
are not known to be tight
there are NP hardness results but they
don't match the corresponding upper
bounds yeah yeah but the question wasn't
about motivate well okay let me just
motivate this I mean maybe Enron has
employees that send emails to each other
at certain and then inside of one month
you might want to know how many emails
have been sent tensor datasets arise in
these never-ending learning language
learning project at CMU where you look
at pairs of words in some contexts and
you look at number of co-occurrences you
know network data where you have packets
and you have source destination may be
port number and you want to know the
number of packets between those entities
using that port so you have very large
tensor datasets a lot of these are
occurring in real time like network
traffic and you'd like to be able to
approximate these okay so the main
question here is that we're looking at
is and I'm gonna focus on third order
tensors and just for simplicity assume
they're n by n by n so given a tensor a
is there an efficient algorithm to
output this rank K approximate tensor a
hat which gives me a good approximation
in Frobenius norm so you know the
Frobenius norm of a hat minus a is at
most some approximation factor alpha
times you know the best possible cost
under any rank a tensor or are there any
inapproximability results and what about
all these other norms that we looked at
for matrices okay problem is clear all
right so you know this natural notion
has not really been studied
maybe you can tell me a few reasons why
so there are multiple problems with this
problem formulation okay well okay so
yeah so no algorithms the cheekiest
guarantee have been proposed so first of
all there's something a little bit
peculiar about tensors I mean but it
doesn't really stop any algorithm from
being proposed I mean the rank of a
matrix is at most n but as someone asked
the rank of a tensor in this case the
third order tensor can be as large as N
squared but you know I mean why does
that really matter for an algorithm
trying to achieve this guarantee so any
any thoughts on why this might well why
this notion hasn't been proposed do you
do you think that this is this can be
done efficiently
the measurement can be beneficial okay
so I just give you this n by n by n what
yeah exactly right so so computing the
rank of a tensor is already np-hard
okay so let's look at the notion we're
claiming we're claiming that we can get
a relative error guarantee right so if I
can get a relative error guarantee what
I can do is I can you know set K to be
equal to one I can see if my cost is
zero set k equal to see if my cost is
zero I can figure out the rank of a
tensor from this relative error
guarantee right it's the first time that
this cost is become zero so okay yeah so
computing the rank of a tensor is
np-hard hostile showed this okay
so that's you know one problem so
there's not going to be an efficient
algorithm for this notion but there's
actually an even more fundamental
problem with this formulation which is
that this this is not even a
well-defined quantity this minimum over
rain came tensors a K of the norm of a K
minus a this actually might not exist so
yeah so let me get into that so the best
rank K solution might not exist due to
what are called border rank issues so
this doesn't happen for matrices but it
happens for tensors and let me say what
that means okay so again the rank of a
matrix as we said it's just the smallest
K so I can write it as the sum of K
outer products K rank one matrices and
we had that same analogous definition
for tensors some of K outer products let
me introduce a new notion called the
border rank of a tensor the border rank
of a tensor is the smallest integer K
such that there exists a sequence of
tensors of rank at most K whose limit is
a
okay so I'm taking all these you know
the border rank is K I'm taking the
smallest K so that there's some sequence
of tensors which gets closer and closer
to a okay so I define you know the rank
of a third order tensor and now I'm
defining the border rank of a third
order tensor okay and I'm gonna show
that the border rank can be smaller than
the rink so let's just let me show you
an example okay
so consider two vectors U and V they're
unit vectors and they're not equal to
each other and let me define the
following third order tensor a the
details are not important but let me
just say them so it's u cross u cross V
Plus u cross V cross u plus V cross you
cross u you can show the rank of this
tensor is three okay it can't be
expressed as a smaller order a smaller
rank tensor however a can be
approximated arbitrarily well by the
following sequence of rank two tensors
which I'll index by B n okay so n is
getting grow up going to infinity again
the details are not so important but
what BN is is it's some rank 1 tensor
minus some other rank 1 tensor okay so
it's rank is it most two
and I can re-express this just by
manipulating this expression as a plus
one over N times some bounded ranked
tenth bounded norm tensor plus one over
N squared times some bounded norm cancer
this is just taking this rank two tensor
and writing it in a different way so a
plus one over n times something plus one
over N squared times something else and
the thing is as n is going to infinity
this B sub n is getting closer and
closer to your tensor a it'll never
reach it will never reach a I mean the
limit is not going to be realized
right I mean a is a rank three tensor
and these are rank two but there's the
you can see that this causes a problem
in the definition that we had for
low-rank approximation of tensors you
know I asked you what's the best rank to
you know give me the best rank two
approximation to this tensor a what are
you going to give me you're going to
give me some rank two tensor with some
it's gonna have some cost I can just
give you a much better rank two tensor
by going farther along in the sequence
there's no way you can get a relative
error guarantee right it's not the the
minimum is not even defined right there
are there ways of dealing with this like
with things like bounding the bit
complexity of your approximation etc but
but yeah in general that notion has
problems one fix that will do here is if
you just add an arbitrarily small
additive error here now this additive
error can be an arbitrarily small
function so like one over N to the N to
the N I mean whatever you want here
that'll fix this issue but but that that
needs to be there to handle these border
rank issues okay any questions yeah
you could have put a ring to cancer
oh I'll put a something with rink larger
than K yes so we're actually going to
sew a by criteria is a solution yes we
have order rank issues let's see so
[Music]
so okay so one thing about this is that
the this is not just this border ink is
not just ranked versus ranked -1 this
can be like ranked versus anything less
than rank so I think because of that
there's I mean you could have you could
have you could have something which is
rank a and and the border rank could be
like 2 or something and then I think
there was still be problems yeah but but
let me think about that yeah yeah any
other questions
okay yeah but by criteria solutions is
one way we're going to deal with
np-hardness by the way so okay let me
get into our results then so yeah
algorithmically will give a by criteria
solution so this is okay because it's
still well motivated we're going to have
a significant parameter reduction which
is one of the motivations
if you insist on a rank a tensor then
what we're going to do is give you an
algorithm which is efficient when K is
not too large okay so it's going to be
in this realm of parametrized complexity
you can think of it as being fixed
parameter tractable in terms of K will
also give a special kind of algorithm
called a if you if you're familiar with
column subset selection algorithms for
lowering cap proximation of matrices
will give the analog for tensors these
are called column row and tube subset
selection algorithms and we'll also
mention some computational hardness
which suggests you know you know which
shows that some of the terms of them are
out in our algorithm are actually
necessary okay so let me just mention
the main by criteria algorithm first
again focusing on third order n by N by
n tensors what we can show is the
following instead of outputting a rank K
tensor we're going to output a rank R
tensor where R is order K squared over
epsilon squared
okay and the guarantee yeah so I'm out
putting these three factors UV and W
there n by r the guarantee is that the
cost of approximating a by u cross V
cross W is at most 1 plus epsilon times
the best cost if I were to use an actual
rank K tensor and it's a randomized
algorithm and the running time is it's
very fast so it's number of nonzero
entries of a plus n times a polynomial
in K over epsilon okay I mean so not
only is it polynomial time but it's
actually you know optimal time up to
this low order term because you do have
to read all the nonzero entries of a
tensor to get a low rank to get any
relative error okay so you know so
there's some blow up here instead of
rank K it's rank K squared over epsilon
squared any questions ok if you insist
on rank K tensor then we also have an
algorithm where we output yeah u cross V
cross W it's rank K now and randomized
algorithm the running time now the
problem is np-hard it's not going to be
fully polynomial in all the parameters
so what happens here we get the same
running time as before n NZ of a plus n
times poly K epsilon plus a term which
is exponential in K squared over Epsilon
okay so just some comments about this so
it's fixed parameter tractable I mean so
that even if K is is large is like
square root log n we still get a
polynomial time algorithm and often in
these applications caves
I mean it's typically small but okay so
let me mention this column subset
selection algorithm for tensors but
before doing that let me just say what
it is for matrices so if you haven't
seen what's called the CU r
decomposition this is special
of low-rank approximation where the
factors these low rank factors consist
of actual columns subsets of columns and
subsets of rows a subset of rows of your
matrix
so given this M by d matrix a we want to
output three matrices see it's a small
subset of columns of a are is a small
subset of rows of a and U is just some
arbitrary you know tiny connecting
matrix so that C times u times R has the
right dimensions typically you want you
to be rank K so C is going to have
slightly more than K columns are will
have slightly more than K rows but if u
is rank K this will still be a rank K
approximation and the goal is just for
this to be a good rank K approximation
so the cost of using CU r is at most 1
plus epsilon times the optimal cost and
you know the nice thing about this is
that since your factors consist of
actual subsets of columns or rows if
your original matrix had sparse columns
or rows for example then your factors
would be sparse this also you know gives
you some interpretation of what the
factors mean maybe these are the
important columns etc a natural question
is how many samples of columns and rows
are needed here what we showed a few
years ago with boot Cetus is that you
can get simultaneously get cave reps
long columns and grows the rank of U is
K and we can do this in roughly N and Z
of a time times a log factor and there's
also sort of a hard matrix a matrix a
for which you need simultaneously cave
reps long columns and rows in this work
one thing we do is we improve this to
sort of an optimal running time of n in
Z of a time but what I would say is more
important is what we do is we give the
first analog for tensors so for tensors
here's your N by N by n tensor and what
you want to do here is choose a subset
of columns
so here's this matrix C is choosing some
columns arbitrarily in this cube so n by
C you should choose a small number of
columns is choosing a small subset of
rows here here's this matrix R and a
small subset of tubes here okay here are
the tubes that you're choosing and just
like for matrices there's some
connecting tensor you here which kind of
glues these together and gives you an N
by N by n tensor and the way you can
think of this is so when I take my
subset of columns my subset of rows in
my subset of tubes I take some column
here some arbitrary row here and some
arbitrary tube here and I take the outer
product of these three vectors and I
have some coefficient for that outer
product in you and I take a different
triple column row and tube and I have
some other coefficient in U and U is
just adding up all of these outer
products and so yeah so I mean that's
just what this notation indicates and so
what you can do is you can ask for a
low-rank approximation of this form and
which is a 1 plus epsilon approximation
to the low-rank problem and you can ask
again how many samples of columns rows
and tubes are necessary and sufficient
for this problem what we show is we
first give a you know fully polynomial
time algorithm like input sparsity time
it doesn't achieve the optimal number of
columns rows and tubes it gets some
polynomial and k-epsilon yeah question
[Music]
spot stencil you must watch this so that
it expires means the number of non-zeros
is proportional to n okay yeah yeah okay
so yeah exactly so yeah if this is
really exactly n then our overall time
would be dominated by this and it would
be n times polynomial and caver epsilon
I mean so you know this could be as
large as n cubed it really depends on
the application I I mean yeah I mean it
just I think it's really application
specific I mean so you could have yeah I
mean so if K and epsilon or K rap song
is not too large this is sort of like
order n this is typical of sparsity of
matrices but yeah I think anywhere
between N and n cubed is yeah yeah okay
yeah so we don't get the optimal number
of columns rows and tubes here we get
Polyakov or epsilon and we don't
actually find a rank K tensor you to
glue these together it's but it's but
it's polynomial time if you know if you
really want the right parameters like
the optimal number of columns rows in
tubes you can get K epsilon for all
three of those we can show that that's
optimal we can also find the rank K
tensor you but you know if we can find
all this stuff then we're getting some
rank K tensor which is approximating our
input is achieving a 1 plus epsilon a
good approximation and as I said the
best thing we know how to do in that
case is to spend some exponential time
in K epsilon K squared over epsilon so
we do have that additional term here
yeah and as I said there is a hard
instance which which matches this so
okay questions yeah Moses
like this designer what oh you want to
yeah that I've seen that that that's
that's been done before if you if you
want to instead optimize over a good
column subset selection algorithms as
opposed to actually rank K matrices yeah
I'm not sure yeah so what would yeah so
I guess the question is like what would
happen to the complexity in that case
right yeah yeah yeah well no no sorry I
mean we do no other oh I see so it also
depends on the parameters that you put
here like if you put K by K by K you're
saying yeah yeah I'm not sure yeah yeah
yeah even for matrices are not exactly
sure what the answer is there yeah yeah
question if you want video money it's
overall makes not a speak it's very
similar problem you know the questioning
me
Oprah question yeah yeah I mean one
thing you means solving tend to
regression or yeah yeah I mean so there
are algorithms no it's not trivial yeah
but yeah let me get into the algorithm
and yeah okay
Oh hardness so I want to try to justify
some of these exponential running times
that we have so we can strengthen
Hofstede's hardness result using modern
technology so if someone gives you this
n by N by n tensor and a rank parameter
K I mean which has rank K and you want
to figure out what the rank is so you
want to output a number T which is not
exactly the rank but it's at least the
rank and it most a fixed constant times
the rink for a certain constant then we
can show assuming the exponential time
hypothesis which this means that you
know three satisfiability on instances
of size n
takes two to the Omega n time like you
basically can't do anything than just
trying all assignments if you make this
code complexity assumption then we can
show that to solve this problem you
actually do need to spend roughly 2 to
the K time okay and there are other
complexity assumptions they're
randomized versions of of the
exponential time hypothesis due to FICA
if you make those assumptions you
actually get no you can't solve this
problem in less than 2 to the K time now
as I said like we're actually solving
this problem you know we can approximate
that we can figure out what the rank is
with our algorithm which is achieving
relative error we're getting a 2 to the
K squared in the upper bound so there's
a you know there's a gap here this gap
is related to this problem I mentioned
earlier of actually constructing
explicit tensors of large rank because
in these kinds of proofs what you end up
doing is maybe reducing from 3sat you
end up building a tensor of large rank
and an explicit tensor and we don't know
how to build such tensors with rank
larger than K so I mean we don't know
how to build K by K by K tensors with
rank much larger than K this is some
kind of barrier for improving this but
you know I know ok so any questions
another thing you could ask is our
running time is exponential in the
accuracy so but we can get a hardness
result in terms of the accuracy
parameter epsilon as well so for rank
one tensors already the hardness is
there so if I have a tensor a and I want
to find U cross V cross W it's a Rank 1
tensor so that the the Frobenius norm is
at most 1 plus epsilon times opt what we
can show again under the same complexity
assumptions is that there's no algorithm
for solving this that runs in time
significantly less than 2 to the 1 over
epsilon to the 1/4 ok now we were
getting 2 to the 1 over epsilon when K
was equal to 1 again this is not optimal
but it is suggestive
you know some kind of exponential
dependence is needed okay so let me just
you know quickly give a slide those are
our results let me just quickly give a
slide about the technique that we use to
get these bounds we call it an iterative
existential argument and it works as
follows so I had this n by N by n tensor
the algorithm is is is really really
simple okay so this is all it does so I
this n by N by n tensor and I can
flatten it into a matrix which is n by n
squared ok so if I have an N by n by n
tensor I can take say all the row column
faces each one is an N by n matrix and I
can put them all next to each other that
gives me an N by n square matrix but I
could have also taken all the row tube
faces and put those next to each other
or the column tube faces so I can
generate three different kinds of n by N
squared matrices these are called
flattening of the tensor let me call
those a 1 a 2 and a 3
they're N by N squared matrices then
what we do is we choose a random matrix
s 1 which is say a random Gaussian
matrix it's gonna have N squared rows
and it's gonna have a really small
number of columns the number of columns
is s it's going to be order K over
epsilon so what's gonna happen here is I
mean when I compute a 1 s 1 it takes
this n by N squared matrix and it
squashes it down to an N by s matrix
with a very small number of columns
right I'm gonna take a to this other
flattening it's n by N squared I'm gonna
squash down the number of columns to
roughly I mean I mean to s again to K R
Epsilon I'm gonna take a 3 and I'm gonna
squash it down to K R epsilon columns
and then the argument is just that there
exists a good you know a rank K tensor
which is a 1 plus epsilon approximation
which is in the span of all triples of
outer products of columns here comes
here and columns here so what does that
mean
I take one of the columns here you know
this is a very tiny matrix there are
only s columns I take one of the columns
here I take one of the columns here I
take one of the columns here there only
s cubed choices and you know each one is
giving me a rank 1 tensor I'm gonna take
the outer product of these 3 I look at
the span of these things and that
contains a good rank a tensor good means
a 1 plus epsilon approximation to the
best rank a tensor ok so if I wanted to
by criteria algorithm I'm done all I do
is I know a I just flatten it in three
different ways and I sketch it down to a
very tiny matrix and end by s matrix and
I just take all triples of outer
products that's my by criteria solution
those triples they span a good rank a
tensor that's what so we show this and
I'll show it on the slide but that's the
algorithm it's the algorithm clear just
flatten and sketch in three different
ways and the span contains a good
solution now yeah so if you want to by
criteria solution you can stop you can
optimize it a little bit if you want a
actual rank K tensor you can do some
kind of enumeration inside of the span
to find it and that's why you get an
exponential term let me get into the
details of why this this holds okay so
let me define opt to be the cost of the
best rank K tensor approximating a
okay and let me say that you star cross
V star across W star that is the best
ranked a tensor approximating a okay I I
don't know any of these factors but let
me just pretend that I somehow knew v
star and W star
so let me think of those as being fixed
this is just a hypothetical argument
then I can set up an optimization
problem in terms of this last factor you
write I can I can ask the question what
is the minimum over N by K matrices U of
U cross V star cross W star minus a that
norm all right I know the solution U is
U star right I'm just setting up this
problem okay but the nice thing about
this so the Frobenius norm is just the
sum of squares of differences if I
flatten the tensors instead of being n
by n by n I flatten them to n by N
squared I can just take the sum of
squares of differences of these matrices
it's the same norm right I mean so I'm
gonna flatten a this and I'm gonna get a
1 say a flatten in a certain direction
and I'm gonna also flatten this rank K
tensor all right so what am i doing I'm
taking the I'm taking the outer product
of three vectors and I'm adding up K of
those each of those vectors is
n-dimensional instead of doing that what
I could do is I could take the outer
product of one vector which is
n-dimensional and an N square
dimensional vector and add up K of those
right so so what would that be so
instead of you know taking the outer
product of the first column of U the
first column of e star in the first
column W star I could take the outer
product of the first column of U and the
N squared dimensional vector which is
already you know the outer product of V
Star and W star and and and written as a
long n square dimensional row why do I
do this because I take this tensor
problem and I convert it to a matrix
problem
right so instead of you know this n by K
cross n by K cross n by K I have an N by
K matrix and I'm multiplying it by a K
by N squared matrix where the rows are
these n square dimensional you know
vectorization z-- of the outer products
of columns of v star and W star it
converted a tensor problem to matrix
problem clear everybody ok why do I do
that well now I can leverage all this
theory that we have for sketching for
data dimensionality reduction for
matrices so let me say what that means
so I've written this as a matrix problem
I mean I'm still like hopeless because I
don't know V Star W star let me just
call this K by N squared matrix
z1 some unknown matrix okay now the main
point of this is that what's known for
matrices is that if I have this matrix
problem if I choose a random Gaussian
matrix s1 and replace this matrix
problem by sketching on the right so
instead of this matrix problem I replace
it by I replace u z1 with u z1 s 1 where
s 1 is this Gaussian matrix which is
supposed to squash down the number of
columns and I replace a 1 with a 1 s1 I
get this much smaller matrix problem and
what's known is that if I solve this
much smaller problem I solve for you
then I get a good one plus epsilon
approximation to the original matrix
problem this theory of dimensionality
reduction for matrices ok but what is
the solution to this small matrix
problem you can write it in closed form
like what is this problem this is just a
regression problem right I yeah I don't
know z1 but I'm pretending I know z1 so
I have Z 1 s 1 a 1 s 1 and I'm solving
for you that's just a regression problem
I can write down the solution in closed
form u hat is equal to a 1 s 1 times Z 1
s 1 pseudo inverse that's just how you
write down the solution to least squares
ok but why do I care I mean III don't
know what z1 is
I have no idea what this factor is but
what is the point of this you had people
see you like what was the point of this
whole thought experiment like this you
had is inside of the column span of a 1
s1
a 1s1 has a very small number of columns
right it only has que ver epsilon
columns so I I didn't need to know what
z1 s one was I mean there there's some
matrix here that you know makes this
rank K but if I'm fine its topping with
something a little bit larger rank like
haver Epsilon then I I'm done I know a1
I know s one I just compute them the
column span contains something which is
which is a you know which is good
because what this guarantee says is that
if I plug in this solution U hat back
into the original tensor problem or
equivalently into the original matrix
problem I get a 1 plus epsilon
approximation so that's why we call this
an existential argument I mean we made
this argument without knowing V Star and
W star and concluded that there's a good
solution U hat in the column span of a 1
s 1 so to actually get a rank cave me
make a tensor you would have to actually
find these things
let me just yeah almost done so that's
why we called existential why do we call
it a root 'iv well ok so we found this u
hat so that u hat cross V star cross W
star minus a is small right it's our
good solution why don't we just do the
argument again so now let's fix W star
and you had and carry through exactly
the same argument let's flatten in the
second dimension and sketch this let's
do a 2 and sketch that down and going
through exactly the same argument what
you'll do is you'll find a V hat so that
V hat is in the column span of a to s 2
times something you don't know
and now the approximation is 1 plus
epsilon squared because V hat is found
with respect to u hat which you already
found it's iterative and why don't you
do it one more time fix you had in V hat
sketch the last flattening and now
you'll find some W hat which is in the
column span of a 3 s 3 and this will
give you a 1 plus epsilon cubed 1 plus
order epsilon approximation
and so now what's happened is you know
so you carry through this argument and
now you know there are good small
matrices X 1 X 2 and X 3 these are these
unknown these small matrices you don't
know Z 1 s 1 pseudo inverse Z 2 s 2
pseudo inverse C 3 s 3 is reversed you
don't know what they are but you can set
up this optimization problem you know
that there exists a good assignment
X 1 X 2 and X 3 so that a 1 s 1 X 1
cross a 2 s 2 X 2 cross a 3 s X 3 s 3
gives you a good rank a tensor if you
just want to by criteria solution you
can just stop right you just take all
you know outer products of triples of
columns of a 1 s 1 a 2 s 2 an a 3 s 3
you're done if you want a rank 8
solution then you have to solve for x1
x2 and x3 but these are really tiny
matrices right I mean x1 is is order s
by K its s by K so it's it's roughly K
squared over epsilon unknowns and I have
K squared over epsilon unknowns for x2
and x3 I can just set up a you know a
polynomial optimization problem it's
going to take you know exponential time
in the number of variables but find the
number of variables is small it's like K
squared over epsilon and so I can
actually solve this if the rank is small
okay so so that's that's the technique
and let me just wrap up on the last
slide so yes the goal is to find these
factors for tensor low-rank
approximation I explained how to do that
for Frobenius norm but there were all
these other norms for matrices that we
get the first algorithms for for tensors
so we can get entry wise l1 norm for
tensors the approximation factor instead
of being 1 plus epsilon is poly K or
poly K log n we can do asymmetric norms
so maybe the some of the l2 norms of
each face of the tensor or for tensors
you have more options right maybe the
sum of l2 norms of each column of the
tensor there's lots of different kinds
of robust norms you can look at we get
low-rank approximation for those again
these are np-hard they're not going to
be 1 plus epsilon approximations
weighted for being a storm we can get
something for that and
no assumptions on the tensor input
sparsity running time I want to mention
that since our algorithms are based on
sketching taking the tensor flattening
and sketching it down in three different
directions these are useful for
distributed and streaming environments
where you see maybe entries that the
tents are changing very rapidly and you
kind of need to in real time you know
update your your sketch your
representation of the tensor and it's
also useful in distributed environments
and finally just let me mention that
these algorithms the same techniques
apply to other notions of tensor rank so
there's what's called the tucker rank
and the tensor train rank and these
other notions of rank are a little bit
more well-behaved than the canonical
rank that we studied here in particular
they don't suffer from these border rank
issues and ok so that's all yeah
[Applause]